hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
quality control advancements in
therapeutic genome editing and
biomanufacturing
i'm mark lynch of genomic vision and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genomic vision
to learn more visit genomicvision.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send you'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker iman
mastery
account manager at genomic vision iman
you may begin your presentation
thank you mark for the introduction my
name is iman misteri i'm a scientific
account manager at genomic vision
okay welcome to our summer webinar
series
where we are on molecular convenience
applications so during the first session
we presented molecular comping
principles and how it's transforming
the genetic resource through the
analysis of single general molecule
during the second session we you learned
how
molecular company can signify complex
genetic diseases
by a quantifying structural copy number
of ions
and during the third session we
presented
how molecular combing improved
understanding of the replication
kinetics in oncology
field and i'm happy to present today our
last
webinar session on quality control
advancement in therapeutic genome
editing and biomanufacturing
molecular combing is a single
molecule-based technology and we use it
for many applications
for example in human genetics in cancer
research
in drug development and also in genome
engineering and noble therapies
and this will be the focus of my talk
today so i will present genomic
vision-based quality control essay for
therapeutic genome editing
and animal model generation and
biomanufacturing
and i will start my talk with the
application of molecular combing
to cell repetitive genome editing
genome editing and the development of
the cresparcas system
has really reverse revolutionized the
way we really
see science in basic research
it facilitated the development of
cellular and animal models for
functional studies
in the therapeutic field it accelerated
the development of eggs vivo and in vivo
therapies for diseases with unmet needs
it is now also being used to engineer
better cell factories
for the production of the biologics like
for example
recombinant proteins monoclonal
antibodies or vaccines
and last but not least it accelerated
the development
of plants and animals with the desired
economic traits
in the therapeutic field so there is
several clinical studies the using
gene editing tools and also the crest
podcast system that have already started
and the first results from the clinical
trials are very promising
but there is still some safety issues
that need to be addressed with using
these gene editing tools
mainly the p53 mediated response to
double strand blacks
that can lead to cancer formation of
target effects
and also on target arrangements that are
caused by the dna machinery
and that can be quite complex and lastly
translocation that can be caused by
potential of targets or multiplexing
strategies
so the regulatory agencies recommend
to identify and characterize of targets
and also chromosomal translocation
and to evaluate the profile of insertion
and deletions
and all type of mutations generated at
the targeted locus
so it's really important to accurately
characterize and quantify
gene editing events in order to mitigate
the risk benefit balance
and bring this tool safely to the clinic
[Music]
genomic vision we provide a technology
that combines direct visualization
single molecule analysis
and the pyramic panoramic view of the
the the targeted regions
so molecular coming can visualize and
quantify
mid-size variants that are between 2 and
10 kb
in size quantify large variants and
trust locations that can be
more than 10 kb in size it can also
visualize and quantify on target
rearrangement that can be
quite complex like for example
inversions duplications
that can happen a couple of kb away from
the target site
and also exogenous dna integrations so
as an example if
you are using aav to deliver the
cresparcas9 components
or a therapeutic protein we can monitor
put for a potential integration of this
av
into your into into the inducer doppler
sunfix
so of target detection is partially
possible with molecular combing
and requires a prior nomination of this
of target by
another technology
so the hotep digital pcr short and
long great sequencing can also fish are
powerful technologies and can be used to
assess gene editing outcomes but none of
these technologies
combines the the visual and
quantitative aspects that is really
unique to molecular combing
so molecular combing can quantify the
efficiency and fidelity of gene editing
based therapies
and the principle is quite simple so if
for example you are aiming to
induce a targeted edition using respect
9
we will design a set of probes that are
specific to your target focus
we will then visualize uh the the
obscene
the obtained signals and classify them
in different categories
in either unedited molecules edited
molecules
or rearranged molecules and the right
hydrogen molecules
can have a variable variety of
rearrangements at the at the targeted
locus
so we will then quantify each
signals per each molecules per category
of signals
so the efficiency is defined by the
number of edited molecules divided by
the top and total number of molecules
and the fidelity is uh defined by the
number of
arranged molecules and the total number
of molecules and this is how
we will uh we um we assess uh
the the gene edited outcomes and i will
give now
uh two case studies to illustrate what
i'm just saying
so in the first study we used a
molecular combine to validate a 2kb
targeted decision induced by the
cresparcas9 system
so primary fibroblasts that are derived
from patients
harboring a pathogenic mutation between
the oxygen exon 15
and the exon 16 were electroporated with
a
hypernucleoprotein complex to induce a
10kb deletion
at the target site so we designed
a set of probes
that are composed of a process of
different size color
and spacing and that failed of unique
barcode that we call
gmt for genomics morse code that is
really specific to the target focus
and the scheme of this gmc is really
depicted here
at the bottom of the slide and
so here are some some results and so as
a reminder the gmc barcode is
really presented at the top and it
covers a region of 40 kb
in size um so the targeted uh
deletion is uh labeled in uh in green
and it's really the fragment
number uh uh named c
so in the first panel uh this shows
the unedited events so as you can see
here this is examples of a signal that
we can obtain with our fiber vision
scanner
and the the c fragment
in green here is really still present as
you can see here very clearly
and the number of these events is around
80.7 percent
frequency so in the second panel we show
editing events
as and you can clearly see here that the
green fragment
is absent and the efficiency of our
editing
is around 17.7 percent
so importantly in the same sample we
also observe it
on target unintended rearrangements that
are depicted
in the third panel so and these events
are caused by sister chromatid fusions
and happens at 1.6
frequency and this is quite uh quite
high
and it's really difficult to uh to uh
identify this type of uh
rearrangement with another technology
and what is really nice with molecular
coming is that you can
see clearly what is happening and this
gives you also a hint
of what type of mechanism and what type
of
mechanism led to these rearrangements so
we scored more than one thousand signals
per sample to provide a robust safety
safety assessment to our clients
as a summary molecular coming is a
powerful tool
to visualize edited sickness and
quantify their frequency
to visualize and quantify on target or
arrangements especially unbiased
translocation
and also to provide a mechanistic
understanding of the individual
identified
arrangements
i will present now against the second
case study where we monitored
facebook s9 gene editing event at the
bracamon logos
so hack 293 cells were electroporated
with an rna complex to generate a 6.5 kb
deletion
in this case we also compared three
guide and rna pairs
and the position of the left and right
guide rnas
is depicted at the bottom of the slide
[Music]
so we then detected and quantified
intended gene editing events
so in the image presented here on the
top you will have
signals from the white type allele so
the b sequence that we intended to
delete
is still present and at the bottom you
will have an example
of the edited allele as you can see the
beef
the beer fragment is deleted indicated
and
that the editing was efficient
and we quantified the efficiency of this
editing
that ranges between 6.5 to 11 percent
depending of the guide rna pairs
use it
importantly and like in the first case
uh that i showed
we also observed uh on target uh
rearrangements at the from target to
arrangements and
um so the first um the the as a
previously the y-type allele is uh is
depicted at the top of the of the of the
image
and there are legends uh alice at the
bottom and as you can
see here the rearrangement that we
absorb it is quite complex
so the ba fragment has been deleted so
there's a deletion
and also an inverted duplication at the
same time
so we quantified that this time the
frequency of these events that ranged
between 2.6 to 4 percent
depending on the guidelines we also
observed
uh some rearrangements in the control uh
that we
are that we use it and this is also
linked to the fact that the bracket one
locus
is in is a fragile side that
uh that is uh subject to a rearrangement
in um
in um i mean untreated conditions
so it really also pinpoints the
importance of controlling the context of
gene editing
in order really to uh to differentiate
the
editing effects from the naturally
occurring
and basal structural variants
so we then sought to uh compare our
decision frequencies with an alternative
to a technologist
and we then use a droplet digital pcr
so the the the the deletion frequencies
um calculated by droplet digital
pressure is presented in the graph here
and the range of deletion frequencies is
very similar to
what we observed with coming validating
our results
so droplet digital allows for an
absolute quantification of targeted
deletion
but it's really blind to all the rear
arrangements like the complex one that i
just presented
or the sisters chromatid fusion that i
presented in the first case
as a summary molecular combing is unique
in the sense that it enables
both visualization and quantification of
intended and
unintended editing outcomes in a single
experiment
it can detect and quantify large
targeted deletions
without amplification of capture bias
it quantifies the efficiency and the
fatality of gene editing events
unintended on target rearrangements
happened
at a high frequency and sister chromatid
fusions
are the most common arrangement
observant so whether
these rearrangements are persist or are
counter-selected in further divisions
is still in open questions and need
further investigations
so i will now present the application of
molecular coming to transgenic animal
models
so transgenic animal models are very
important for basic research
and also for clinical clinical studies
and it's really a key to
accurately validate the engineered
animals
and why and here i'm going to quote
one of my clients um because the
production of transgenic animal models
by traditional pronuclear injection
results in the random integration of
single and often multiple copies of
transgenes
that can be averaged in concatenates and
this can have a profound effect on
transient expression
it is though critical to deeply
characterize the transient integration
side
and also the pathetic integration to
conclude that the desired phenotype is
associated with the transgene
so we used molecular combing to
characterize a transgenic integration
pattern so we designed it
by a three-color barcode that is
specific to our transgene
and we found that the transient
integrated as
a 600kb compatiment of 40 copies
so an example of signals from this
concatenate is presented
here and the number of copies are
annotated on the top
so from the copy number 1 to the copy
number 10
we found that the transgenes are
arranged in a head
to tail orientation the copy number
time nine was found to be a
rear hundred so it's a truncated topic
and as you can see in the
la enlargement of the signal the blue
fragment that is encoding the gene of
interest
is deleted so from copy number 10 to
copy number
40 there is a change in orientations and
all the copies are oriented in the tail
to head orientation
so molecular combing really allows for a
fine characterization of transgene
integration patterns
and this uh i mean this deep
characterization of transgenes
is really key in the field of gene and
cell therapy and for animal model
generations
like the generation of humanized mouse
models
but also it's written a regulatory
requirement
in the bioproduction field and i will
present
uh some examples
in the in the in my talk now
so a population of uh cells that are
usually clonally derived
is used to produce a biologic that can
be a recombinant protein a vaccine
or a monoclonal antibodies and it's
really important to characterize the
transgenes during the cell line
development and banking
in order to minimize potential risk and
also
to ensure a consistent product quality
and manufacturing stability
[Music]
after the current guidelines for
australian characterization
they recommend to document the coding
sequence of the expression construct
the copy number of the transient its
structural integrity and also its
integration pattern
molecular coming basic quality control
meet with these
requirements so
our molecular coming based quality
control can be used throughout the cell
line development
pipeline it can be used for screening
and transition after cell engineering or
singular electronic
and it can be used for genetic
characterization and genetic stability
testing
during cell line expansion and banking
so our quality control essay can
identify
the vector identity its integrity and
copy number
and also co-integration events like for
example bacterial
contamination if this is something that
is suspected
and last but not least structural
rearrangements that can happen
uh in the transient or also in the
target locus
so we can both monitor random uh
integrations
and also targeted integration in the
case you if
you are using the krespace9 system to
induce
uh to introduce your tangent into safe
harbor to have a consistent uh
expression of this of this function
so we can of course estimate the number
of copy numbers or uh
provide an absolute quantification of
these copies depending
on the integration strategy that you are
using
will provide the characterization of
integration by then
and also quantification of potential
arrangements that can happen at the
targeted
locus in case of the targeted transient
integration
so genomic vision is supporting several
pharmaceutical companies including
sanofi
enzyme where we used our quality control
essay
to uh characterize their uh so their
their their cell banking uh process
and we are also a member of the genome
in the construction that
conveys different stakeholders in the
general editing fields
and the aim of this consortium is really
to develop standards
and methods that are needed to improve
the confidence
of using this genome editing tools
to conclude i really hope that i
convinced you today that through the
analysis of hundreds of single dna
molecules
molecular combing represents a powerful
analytical tool
to generate high quality salvage and
monitor their stability
throughout the manufacturing process and
this really really a critical step in
the development and production of any
biological drug
so a molecular company can also be used
to help
developers of gene and cell therapists
to monitor
unintended biological consequences of
genome engineering
in order to refine their strategy
and to bring self-alterative therapies
into the clinic
as a take-home message molecular combing
is a quantitative method
it allows single molecule counting of
hybridization signals without
antiquification bias
it is a sensitive model methods so we
can go up to a 1
500 equivalent of genome per sample to
reach a sensitivity
sensitivity of 0.25 and this really
allows to identify rare events
it is visual methods and this is really
a
key uh for monocle combing because it
allows a wrong
long-range view of the targeted area and
this will help in identifying large and
complex patterns
including concatenates like i showed
in the example during my presentation
and this type of
complex structure are usually missed by
a lecture generation
sequencing and lastly it's really
orthogonal method to ngs and pcl based
essay
so our quality control essay is provided
as a service
and we have a different type of services
that can be tailored to your knees
so the easy comb and the easy comp plus
it's really start from the sample you
send us the sample we take
your samples and take care of the rest
um so either we send you a
full report for the easy comp plus or we
give you access to our software
to our software to analyze your data um
if needed and this will be the easy
conver it's just the easygoing
for the easy scan so it's really for um
an access to our imaging system and
this is for the if you want to um to set
up the technology
uh in-house
thank you very much for your attention
and if you know want to know more about
our services and products
please contact us at says dot robots
genomic
vision dot com we would happily schedule
a record project
to discuss your projected needs
so also all our summer webinar series
are now available in demand
thank you again for your attention and
i'm happy to take questions
thanks iman for the informative
presentation today
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
with that let's get started
iman the first question that's coming in
is about the services um
and how this actually works so the
question is do you provide
services i saw in your presentation that
we do but how do those services actually
work could you elaborate a little bit
more on that please
iman we're having some difficulty
hearing you
okay it's always okay
yes yeah so we are we we do provide
services and these
services are tailored to your needs so
we have
four type of services
um so we have an um so the full the
end-to-end uh service solution so you
send us your samples
we uh take we do the the the molecular
combing the impetization the scanning
um and the analysis of the data and then
we send you full uh full report
so we also have another another service
where we
stop at the we do the experimental part
and then the scanning uh and then and
and we will give you access to our
software so that you can analyze
your um the data yourself so this is
what we call easy comb
and easycom plus uh comes with the full
uh full analytical part and the report
then we also have what you call an easy
scan and so this is an access
to our um to our um
scanning system um and for this
um it's if you are interested in uh
in um in setting up the technology uh
in-house
you can purchase our um our fiber comp
system
and we will uh we will accompany you and
uh
and help you in getting uh coming up and
running in your lab
and then we will give you access to the
to the scanning
services and the the software it says so
this is how
our services work
thanks iman the next question that's
coming through
is what is the sensitivity in general of
molecular calming
um so with molecular combing we can
reach a
sensitivity sensitivity of 0.25
so this is something that we are we do
in a routine
and we can also go lower uh
i um we have some example where we could
see some rearrangement at a very low
frequency um and so this is also a uh we
we can we can go below 0.25 25
okay thanks iman another question that's
coming through
is it possible to identify inversions
with the
molecular combing technology
uh yeah absolutely so um so the
principle would be
very similar to what i showed for the
deletions
so um so as long as we can design a
barcode that will
allow us to identify the inversion so
it's um so it's possible
it's just a um we can do it for um
for inversion that are uh bigger than uh
than three kb
so lower than 3kb it would be
challenging
but everything that would be uh
bigger than 3kb is totally uh possible
okay thanks iman
another question coming through and i
apologize i do not know what aav is but
let me read out the question anyway
do you have any experience with aav is
the resolution sufficient to visualize
paternal or tetano aav integration at
cut
site oh okay so av is admiral associated
viruses
so we do not have experience whether
with them with aav itself
but uh but we um but as long as uh
so the a visual is around i think
between 4 and 4.7
kb so it's really in our range of
resolution so we can design a set of
prop
that is uh specific to the av and we can
of course monitor if this av integrates
at a particular locus so it's uh
it's it's really something that we can
we can we can monitor
and we know that from some publication
in the literature
um av can integrate uh in double fanback
that are
induced by the use of gene editing tools
so we absolutely we can monitor the
integration of av
okay thanks iman we're showing one more
question here on the list
and that is how frequent these sister
chromatid fusions events are
wow okay um so um
from our experience so um with the range
that we found it varies between
0.2 to uh four percent
so um so it's it's viable and
i think it also depends on the locus and
maybe on the
the targeted locus and its position uh
if it's uh telomeric or
or centromeric so uh so this is um
yeah so the ferrule quantity is viable
uh and it depends
on the position and this is also what
was found by um
publish it also on common cryptis uh i
guess and that found
that sister committed fusion also
happened
at a similar range
okay thanks e-man hopefully that
answered the questions from the audience
um we are not showing any further
questions
so with that i'd like to thank again
iman for your time today
and your important research and
presentation here
we'd also like to thank elaborates for
facilitating today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank also the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions for
any questions that are still
pending you can still submit those
during the on-demand period
and they'll be addressed via the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast along with the other three
webcasts
from genomic vision are available on
demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage that you share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
thank you so much for all your time and
participation in today's webinar and for
those that attended
all four webinars we thank you very much
for that
thank you and good day